there's a woman who just went viral on
this point
a woman who posted a tick-tock video
so many problems begin with posting
tick-tock videos she posted a tick-tock
video
about how she was talking to her father
and
convinced him to vote for joe biden just
take a listen she opens this is my 55
year old conservative dad she's holding
up little cards
has never voted democrat in his life
he's dying of
aplastic anemia we've had some intense
exchanges
yeah presumably about him voting for
trump this year
what a way to waste time with your dad
who's dying which has been painful
since we'll almost certainly lose him
in the next few weeks and months
he has six daughters who love him dearly
yesterday he was
so excited to tell me he just voted for
biden harris 2020 for exclamation points
because it matters to my girls
and my girls matter to me
vote for the guy who respects women
if my very republican dad can
so can you i think i'm going to vote for
the guy
who is supported by people who respect
their parents
their dying parents this woman is sick
she has got a sickness
that a lot of people i think have right
now in this culture
almost exclusively on the left can you
imagine this she says
my dad is dying how sad is that he's
dying of a
disease that i believe uh makes it
difficult for your blood to carry oxygen
i think that's what aplastic anemia is
and we're having these intense exchanges
yeah of course you would that's what you
do
when your parent is dying in these very
intense moments it's a terribly sad
time and the intense exchanges are about
donald trump donald trump
could you imagine wasting your
precious remaining moments with your
parents on donald trump or any
politician for that matter
how sick how warped does your head have
to be and then
to exert all this emotional manipulation
on a
dying man your dying father
to vote for joe biden who gives a damn
who cares joe biden doesn't even care
right some days he doesn't even know
he's running for president
joe biden who doesn't believe in a thing
that's it that's that's what you want
the last moments to be
sick stuff now what's really this
obviously isn't about joe biden because
or come out kamala harris for that
matter because
neither of them have any beliefs they're
the least inspiring politicians ever
just about what this is is
a religious cult progressivism leftism
secular liberalism whatever you want
called
is a religious cult because a more
typical reaction if a parent or a loved
one is dying is to consider
eternal questions where do we go after
we die
what is this life about what am i made
for what is what is
is there something more than this life
try to get right with god
if you do have a faith you'd like to
nudge
your friends and family members over to
that faith
maybe get baptized maybe if you're
already baptized confess your sins
receive the eucharist
receive the sacraments get right with
god
and that's what this woman i think is
doing too she's saying get right with
god
but but in the cult of secular
liberalism that the sacrament is voting
for this crook
joe biden that's the sacrament is voting
it's why you have to vote vote or die
we might say receive the sacraments or
die in the in the eternal life
they're saying vote or die you have to
vote why
vote it doesn't it's fine my life will
go on if i don't vote
if i didn't know anything about the
issues i it would be better if i didn't
vote
but you have to this is the last data i
know we've only got a few moments left
vote for joe biden how
sad how deeply sad is that for this
woman
for her family for the country
very sad stuff very crazy stuff you
should not be doing that
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you